tamar braxton deletes her Instagram amid  drama with her estranged husband Vincent  Herbert nothing in my life felt right  you are entitled to do whatever you want  to do you're a grown woman  the 40 year old singer did just that  getting rid of her count on the social  media platform entirely on Wednesday  after going off on a woman claiming to  be pregnant with her ex's baby over the  holidays which Vincent has denied in a  now-deleted post the reality star wrote  in part he's a real piece of work  shaking my head Happy New Year folks  ladies and gentlemen know that 2018 is a  fresh start and if I can leave this liar  you can leave yours too marriage is not  easy the controversy comes just two  months after tame our file for divorce  from Vincent after nine years of  marriage the former couple have one son  four year old Logan we need to kind of  take a step back and just kind of like  hit the reset button and figure things  out  [Music]